hey Mom can you drive me today are you
ready to go now yeah just give me like
five seconds
[Music]
by that logic we should just occupy
every Country Joe I agree with you Lila
thank you Ziggy how do you agree with
Lila oh [ __ ] excuse my brain for knowing
what not to say
I know it'll get better
cats thanks for tuning in
Mom did you open my doorbells [ __ ] I'm
sorry did you try to open the door while
I was live streaming what's live
streaming that's where I have 20 000
followers and I'm validated and I'm
starred which is Terror hard to get just
make sure you don't play the blues what
white people playing blues music is
cultural appropriation I play classic
folk rock with alternative influences I
don't know what that means
and then you called the police I called
them you're in the right place you're
safe and you'll have two beds for as
long as you need he's my little knight
in shining armor well it's true kids are
just pure love you know what I mean
what the hell are you doing installing a
red beak in the light so people know
when I'm live streaming and by people I
mean you
go to politics you think I'm stupid no
no I didn't say that I brought you this
hat Kyle it was my son's but he no
longer wears it I don't know what he
wears anymore
[Music]
age can't bring themselves to be kind
Jesus Ziggy and you can't help yourself
you're a special person
are you happy I think so why are you
asking me as I'm reading this article
about teen suicide and it's highest in
your age group okay thanks
mom's home
when you were a little boy you're my
little Ally your life was going to be
happier you were going to be one of the
good ones and then something switched in
you
you stopped being interested in anything
outside your own little world
can you take me to school are you ready
to go right now I'm right here dude
foreign
[Applause]